[Music]
genius I think he scores very high there
who also came out of nowhere he was the
first Grandmaster from India I'm going
to give him a nine here entertaining I
don't definitely can be entertaining
both as the chess player and as as a
person but I feel like he doesn't quite
reach the levels of of some of the
others so he's gonna get a he's gonna
get a seven here in terms of influence
people used to say about him that he
would always be the one who plays a good
idea of the second person to play a very
good idea so that he would always pick
up on great ideas from from others he
was extremely or still is extremely
adaptable but he wouldn't necessarily
always come up with them himself but on
the other hand he has influenced an
entire country I will give him an eighth
year in terms of Sanity I think this is
going to be a perfect 10 from from
Ireland